I have to make notes because a lot of my
inspiration comes from meeting people or
going outside of the country or going
around a corner and tomorrow
neighborhood and talking to a five year
old little boy.
It's mainly kids,
man.
I always say this kids bugging me out
because they have no fear,
nothing.
My little niece,
she's two years old,
but she's fierce,
nothing and she has no concept of
reality as we know it.
That always inspired me to write for
some reason,
man,
it gives me a moment.
Talking to them gives me a moment to
step back and look at the world for what
I know this case is that always tripped
me out cause I told them about the story
when I seen him when I was eight,
nine years old with two on Rosecrans.
We're shooting a video of my
neighborhood in Compton when two blocks
down and got me.
By the time we got me,
everybody was out there.
It was like pandemonium.
He put me on his shoulders and that it
was Dr Dre and um,
two part,
right.
Then fast forward 15 years later,
I'm in the studio world and I'm telling
him that story.
I was one of the kids out there as much
as he remembers him.
Crazy,
crazy to me,
which just me being an ultimate fan,
I'm still a fan to this day,
but to actually sit down and have
conversations beyond the music,
he wasn't just a figment of my
imagination.
I was watching on TV screen.
The people are watch.
They just didn't get there on a pure
luck.
They actually worked hard and they are
human beings.
We're real emotion,
real dry,
real consistency,
real hunger.
You know,
deep down we're all kids at heart and I
know I am.
I'm the biggest kid,
you know,
so I can be able to relate and
communicate them,
communicate with them in a way that I
watch.
Most adults can't sit there and hold a
conversation,
you know,
and go back to the studio man,
or write them most bugged out song,
you know,
just because it just gave me,
like I said,
it gives me a chance to sit back and
allow myself and look at the
perspectives of the different spectrum
of having responsibilities and not
having any at all.
And I have to remember these things.
I have to write them down and then five
or three months later,
I have to find that same emotion that I
felt when I was inspired by definite
process.
It's working process.